two one go
[Music]
okay watch the playback no no I mean
let's see how this first one go anyone
says cut say it's in my face where I can
see you ornery is heaven and I got a lot
of feelings but I'm gonna take Chris's
lead I'm gonna save him for Instagram
thanks a bunch
[Music]
hi everyone its charlie so we have a
whole bunch of Ironman deleted scenes
from Avengers end game as well as his
very last Marvel scene that he filmed
ever like that's a picture wrap on Iron
Man for Avengers end game and I know
that brings up the question does that
mean that he didn't film any scenes for
spider-man far from home because it does
seem like that's meant to be sort of an
epilogue for his relationship with
spider-man so I will address that during
the video Kevin Feige also did a reddit
AMA you probably saw people posting
stuff from it all last night because it
was pretty epic he teased the return of
the real Mandarin into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
remember the Marvel one-shot from Iron
Man 3 all hail the king in the real
Mandarin scene the ten rings he says
they're actually planning on paying that
off eventually so I'll talk about that
too if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos it's only gonna get crazier we
also have all the New Avengers spin-off
TV shows that are coming to the Disney
Plus streaming service later this year
of course I'll be doing videos for that
stuff too there is a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment about the movie on
the video starting with the footage
obviously that first deleted scene is
just during that final fight with Iron
Man and the other Avengers going against
Thanos and him trying to take the Nano
Iron Man gauntlet from them I would say
in terms of payoff that fight scene
against Thanos was probably better than
the infinity war scene on Titan of them
fighting fan OHS so when you look at it
as an entire part of the film the end
game fight scene wound up being bigger
because that was like the last 30
minutes of the film was that huge battle
instead of just like 10 or 15 minutes
during the Titan battle in infinity war
ii deleted scene where he's yelling at
the cameras is Iron Man inside the
Avengers base after he's come back
midway through the film when they're
still developing their plan about
building the nano gauntlet and snapping
everyone back because of the way Robert
Downey jr. films his scenes he probably
has some of the most deleted footage of
all just because he'll try a whole bunch
of different stuff but they'll give him
a script but a lot of times in the
moment he'll just come up with his own
take on
whatever the scene is gonna wind up
being just because he's fantastic a lot
of actors can't do that like if they try
to come up with their own dialogue it
would sound ridiculous but if you've
ever watched the behind the scenes for
Robert Downey jr. especially back when
Joss Whedon was doing the original
Avengers movie what he would do is is
when he was in the heads-up display
Robert Downey jr. would sit there Joss
Whedon would sit just off camera and
just spit lines at him to try so this
probably terabytes in terabytes of
deleted scenes with RDJ just trying a
bunch of different versions of scenes
and the movies that he's been in but a
lot of the finished ones will probably
wind up on the Avengers in-game blu-ray
when they release it later this summer
so no worries whatever they end up
putting on that blu-ray I will totally
do videos for that stuff the other scene
that he posted is his official final
last scene that he ever filmed for any
kind of MCU movie because even though
spider-man far from home comes out later
this summer they filmed it before
Avengers end game was finished before
they did all those reshoot so I am
expecting some voiceover dialogue maybe
a message that Ironman recorded for
spider-man posthumously just as a way to
make spider-man feel better about being
on his own so to speak going forward
like even though I won't be around I'm
kind of all over the place and I'll
always be with you kind of thing I'm not
expecting any kind of Ironman force
ghosts or anything like that until we
get to Secret Wars territory and you
have alternate universe versions of Tony
Stark coming back but the big thing you
guys probably heard is Kevin Feige
revealing that the real Mandarin of the
ten rings from that Marvel one-shot all
hail the king during Iron Man 3 we'll be
coming back so there was a question
where someone asked him during his
reddit AMA races are there any plans to
incorporate the ten rings from the first
Ironman
or the real quote-unquote Mandarin
teased in all hail the king in the
future and Kevin Feige his response just
was yes meaning that they're obviously
intending on bringing that character
back and doing him on screen in a really
big way if you haven't seen that scene
in a long time it's been a while since
they've done a Marvel one-shot that's
kind of what the new Disney Plus
streaming shows are gonna be they're
gonna be made in the style of the Marvel
one-shots it'll just be eight hours with
a big movie level budget so here's the
tag of that scene in them revealing that
there really is a Mandarin obviously
because we were all super surprised that
Ben Kingsley wound up being the fake
version of the Mandarin you don't know
the history of the Mandarin himself
he was a warrior King inspired
generations of men to the Middle Ages
perhaps even further back in time blah
blah blah bloody cares make it so sure
people want and I gave them a good one
it's not the Mandarin they'll remember
it's the name Trevor Slattery it's a
brand tread you're right
and for that sin you will soon suffer
horribly with a hole in your body for
every ring of our faith step sorry well
you heard me
you killed my Buffalo you're not capable
of pulling that trigger mr. Slattery I'm
an out-of-work actor loved you've no
idea what I'm capable of and thanks to
the CBS network I'm pretty good with a
handgun
Oh consider this a lesson on what's real
and what's not
why do people keep pointing guns at my
head please I don't want to die I don't
want to die
target acquired an imposition extraction
unit mobilize I'm not the one that's
going to kill you mr. Slattery I'm here
to break you out that's nice
not really you see there's somebody who
wants to meet you
Donna him you know
you took his name and now he wants it
back
no sorry I still don't get it so if it's
been a while since you've thought about
the ten rings organization in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe essentially the first
Iron Man film canonized them is a terror
network they just operated in the Middle
East so we didn't really know what their
structure was at the time it was just a
way for them to safely reference the
real Mandarin because he was one of the
biggest Iron Man comic book villains of
the classic Iron Man comics
you may remember way back to the
original comic-con where Kevin Feige
announced that they were making an Iron
Man film this is way before the Marvel
Cinematic Universe became a big thing he
actually said that they were planning on
doing the Mandarin he gave this big plan
and outline that didn't wind up
happening because later they wound up
going with Obadiah Stane as the villain
so then they came to comic-con the next
year and showed off the trailer he joked
about that later he's like you know
plans change all the time if you go back
and you watch me talking about the
original Iron Man film before it came
out we actually thought that it was
gonna be very different before we
started developing the film right now
there's a rumor that the Mandarin
character the ten rings this will all be
part of the shang-chi movie which makes
sense if you're gonna do a film about an
Asian character it's not a very huge
leap to do an Asian villain that also
will help you tie back to the original
Iron Man film they love doing that
anytime you can introduce a new
character in a different way but also
tie it back to original Marvel films and
recontextualize events of previous films
without completely trampling on them it
makes it really cool for fans in the
same way that they sort of
recontextualized the events of the
original Avengers movie with the new
scenes during Avengers end game like you
watch scenes from the original Avengers
movie in ways that you didn't see before
you get like extra little bits almost as
if it's deleted scenes from the Avengers
movie even though it's new footage that
they shot for Avengers endgame so they
do wind up doing the Mandarin during the
Shang Chi movie don't be surprised if
they have a couple of references to the
events of what happened during the
original Iron Man film speaking of other
things that they're bringing back he
also talked about people like Justin
Hammer the leader from The Incredible
Hulk movie he said that those aren't
forgotten characters they could always
be referenced or come back during future
projects and he was also talking about
the Disney Plus streaming shows
jackass whatever where have you been I I
got a book in the time you were gone and
you'll never see me coming
look at this guy what is so special
about him I mean I had an army of robots
what's he got when asked about how the
Disney Plus streaming shows would
connect to the films he also said that
they would completely connect and be
totally relevant to the plot of what
happens in future Marvel phase four
movies so the Avengers spin-off shows
like The Scarlet Witch vision showed the
Captain America Falcon in Winter Soldier
show all the other ones will be part of
their Marvel phase four schedule it's
just that some of it obviously will air
on the Disney Plus streaming service
exclusively and some of them will be
traditional movies like you have in
previous Marvel phases so that gives you
a better idea for how Marvel phase four
is going to work but don't worry when
they start releasing trailers for all
this stuff
I'll do videos for that and explain but
I will be doing episode videos for those
TV shows like I would normally do for
any other TV show there's a bunch of
other deleted scenes and really cool
things about Avengers in game from
behind the scenes that we've been
learning from the Russos extra context
so is there any big Marvel things that I
haven't done videos about or big
questions that you have just leave your
requests in the comments below and I'll
add it to my bonus video list
no worries there's gonna be a whole
bunch of spider-man I'm sure you have a
lot of x-men and Fantastic Four
questions Kevin Feige did say that they
were getting ready to introduce a lot of
his favorite characters from the comics
in the future without revealing big
spoilers about when and who that would
be but because he grew up a hardcore
x-men and Fantastic Four fan I think
he's talking about those characters
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video reflex
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details while
you wait for everything click here for
more avengers endgame deleted scenes and
click here for that brand new Rick and
Morty season four teaser trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome and see you guys tonight
[Music]